[Musique]
comme vous le savez déjà monsieur le
ministre vous trouverez au sein de notre
commission des interlocuteurs attentif
exigeant mais constructif soucieux à
l'image de notre rapporteur Jacques
groperin d'entretenir le dialogue avec
vous et vos service sur des sujets
essentiels pour les élèves et l'ensemble
de la communauté éducative je tiens
je pense en particulier à la question de
l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignement sur lequel nous avons
beaucoup travaillé depuis de nombreuses
années ici à la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et au
cyberhcèlement sur laquelle le Sénat
s'est penché en 2021 ou encore à la
politique d'inclusion scolaire par
ailleurs comme vous le savez sans doute
nous avons créé avec la commission des
lois une mission de contrôle disposant
de pouvoir d'enquête consacré au modalit
de signalement et de traitement par les
pouvoirs publics des pressions menaces
et agressions subies par les enseignants
dont les travaux de cette commission de
cette mission vont vont reprendre et
dans le cadre de laquelle nous aurons
également plaisir évidemment à à vous
entendre mais notre audition du jour
est est
consacrée aux priorités que vous avez
définis dans le cadre de vos prises de
fonction nous aurons aussi l'occasion de
vous entendre dans dans quelques jours
sur le au projet de doix de finance donc
par conséquent mes chers collègues je
vous demanderai cet après-midi de de ne
pas aborder les questions liées au
projet de doit de finance puisque nous
aurons une une
audition d'ici quelques semaines
pouvez-vous ainsi Monsieur le Ministre
nous présenter votre feuille de route à
la tête du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale un mois et demi après la
rentrée pouvez-vous nous dresser un
premier bilan de celle-ci et des
premières mesures forte je pense
évidemment à l'interdiction du port de
de laba ou du report des épreuves de
spécialité du bac au mois de juin que
vous avez été amené à prendre
pourriez-vous nous faire aussi un point
sur la mise en place du pacte enseignant
êtes-vous satisfait des des premières
adhésions des des
enseignants monsieur le ministre je vais
vous laisser la parole pour une
intervention liminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes après vous avoir rappelé que
cette audition est captée et diffusée en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
puis ensuite comme il en est de coutume
je
donnerai la parole d'abord au
rapporteurs que nous n de désigner
Jacques gros Perin et ensuite bien sûr à
chacun des des sén chacune des
sénatrices et chacun des sénateurs qui
souhaitera le faire monsieur le ministre
la parole est à
vous merci monsieur le Président cher
Laurent Laffond mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les
sénateurs vous l'avez dit c'est ma
première audition devant cette
commission mais en réalité c'est ma
première audition parlementaire depuis
mes nouvelles fonction de ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
vous n'êtes donc pas en retard par
rapport au calendrier je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver beaucoup
d'entre vous avec lesquels j'ai eu le
plaisir de travailler dans mes
précédentes fonctions au budget
retrouver Jacques groserrin nous avions
tous les deux été rapporteurs quand
j'étais député de la loi sur
l'orientation et la réussite des
étudiants début du précédent quinena et
on avait eu une CMP conclusive ce qui
montre la capacité qu'on peut avoir à
travailler euh tous ensemble je vous
remercie vraiment de votre invitation à
m'exprimer devant vous dès la reprise de
vos travaux je profite également de
cette opportunité pour saluer et F citer
celles et ceux d'entre vous pour qui
c'est aussi une première audition dans
cette assemblée ou au sein de cette
commission l'éducation nationale est une
préoccupation majeure des Français à
juste titre tant l'école occupe une
place singulière dans notre société et
dans l'histoire de notre nation vous
êtes le relais de cette préoccupation à
travers les travaux que vous menez tant
au sein de cette commission que dans
l'hémicycle c'est donc pleinement
conscient du rôle qui est le vote
notamment en matière de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement et avec la plus
grande rigueur que je tâcherai à
répondre à vos interrogations
aujourd'hui mais évidemment dans les
mois qui viennent l'école je le disais
c'est ce qui réunit les familles et la
République au sein d'une même espérance
commune que chaque enfant de France
puisse par l'école et grâce à l'école
s'élever et s'émanciper qu'aucun destin
ne soit écrit d'avance c'est la promesse
de la République et cette promesse c'est
celle de son école lors de cette rentrée
scolaire j'ai eu l'occasion de préciser
mon ambition pour ce ministère pour ces
quelques 12 millions d'élèves pour leur
famille et pour plus d'un 00000
personnels dont 860000 enseignants c'est
chaque année je le dis un petit miracle
d'organisation que cette rentrée
scolaire et je veux ici remercier de
nouveau très chaleureusement tous les
enseignants les directeurs d'école les
chefs d'établissements tous les
personnels des rectorat qui ont œuvré
pour cette rentrée je souhaite vous
faire part en introduction des échanges
on m'a indiqué qu'il fallait pas être
trop long pour qu'on puisse échanger les
chantiers que j'ai engagé dès ma prise
de fonction et d'abord en vous disant
que je suis lucide malgré le travail
conduit ces dernières années il reste
encore beaucoup à faire pour réparer ce
que j'ai appelé les mots de l'école les
mots de l'école disons-le clairement
sont le fruit de décennies de
sous-investissement d'une absence de
reconnaissance de nos professeurs d'une
contestation de leur autorité comme plus
généralement de l'autorité des savoirs
dans notre société ils sont enfin le
fruit d'une école qui ne garantit plus
toujours le bien-être et j'ose le dire
le bonheur des élèves comme des
personnels voilà pourquoi j'ai fixé à
mon ministère trois priorités claires la
première élever le niveau général la
seconde réaffirmer les droits et devoirs
à l'école et la troisème bâtir une école
qui émancipe et qui rend heureux ma
première priorité c'est donc d'élever le
niveau par un véritable choc des savoirs
un mot d'abord sur le constat mais il
est hélas connu notre pays a connu une
baisse du niveau général ces dernières
décennies un élève de 4e de 2018 avait
le niveau d'un élève de 5e de
1995 en 23 ans c'est 1 an qui a été
perdu quand on regarde aujourd'hui les
évaluations nombreuses qui sont
réalisées chaque année les évaluations
nationales que nous devons à l'action de
Jean-Michel blanqu je dois le dire nous
voyons qu'un élève sur 3 qui rentre en
6e ne sait pas lire écrire et compter
correctement nous voyons que un élève
sur de en classe de 6e ne sait pas dire
combien il y a de quart d'heure dans 3/4
d'heur nous voyons que à l'occasion du
brevet des collèges pour les élèves de
3e 25 % d'entre eux ont moins de 4/ 20
en mathématiques au brevet des collèges
le 4/ 20 estant la note la plus
distribuée en mathématique au brevet des
collèges ce retard s'accumule et se se
et se perpétue tout au long de la
scolarité c'est donc dès les premières
années qu'il nous faut agir nous savons
que pour la maîtrise des savoirs
fondamentaux c'est dès le début de la
scolarité que tout se joue c'est dès le
début que l'on peut éviter un décrochage
qui reste un échec pour tous c'est dès
le début qu'il nous faut replacer au
cœur de l'école la notion d'exigence
l'exigence sans laquelle il n'y a ni
excellence ni égalité des chances dans
notre école républicaine pour cela mon
ministère dispose de moyens historiques
le projet de loi de finances pour 2024
que vous aurez examiné dans les
prochaines semaine prévoit une
augmentation inédite du premier budget
de la Nation je vais pas rentrer dans le
détail puisqu'on aura une audition
dédiée mais simplement pour donner un
chiffre que j'ai donné tout à l'heure
aux questions d'actualité au
gouvernement depuis 2017 l'école a perdu
300000 élèves du fait de la démographie
le budget augmenté de 30 % 300000 élèves
de moins 30 % de budget en plus ça ne
s'est jamais vu dans les dernières
décennies dans le quinquena qui s'ouvre
l'école perdra autour de 400000 élèves
du fait de la démographie qui doit
évidemment nous préoccuper une question
a lieu tout à l'heure sur le sujet et le
budget continuera à augmenter nous avons
amélioré le taux d'encadrement ces
dernières années nous allons continuer à
l'améliorer en 2024 ce ces budgets et
ces moyens supplémentaires nous
permettent de poursuivre un certain
nombre de chantiers d'achever à la
rentrée 2024 le dédoublement des classes
de grandes sections de maternelle en Rep
et REP plus ce qui permettra à notre
pays d'enseigner à 500000 élèves en
grande section CP et CE1 dans des
classes dédoublées précisément là où
nous devons briser les inégalités de
destin de poursuivre l'effort d'accueil
des 2 ans en très petite section avec 60
dispositifs supplémentaires en quartier
politique de la ville soit une
augmentation de 50 %. de renforcer
l'apprentissage de la lecture et la
pratique de l'écriture dès le CP et tout
au long de l'école élémentaire il y a
urgence c'est pourquoi nous renforçons
aussi la lecture de textes longs dè le
CM1 j'ai eu l'occasion de l'annoncer
l'écriture d'au moins un texte par
semaine en CM2 et les stages de réussite
durant les vacances scolaires dans le
cadre du dispositif école ouverte dont
300000 élèves ont bénéficié l'an dernier
les nouvelles évaluations nationales en
CM1 qui se sont déroulé ces dernières
semaines et dont les résultats sont en
cours de consolidation nous permettront
également d'identifier les besoins de
chaque élèv pour mieux y répondre enfin
en 6e cela nous permet de déployer des
SEP rentrées une heure de plus par
semaine en français et en mathématiques
par groupe d'élèves répartis par besoin
parallèlement aux enseignements aux
classes entières pour des cours de
soutien ou d'approfondissement dans ces
matières fondamentales c'est la clé de
même que la généralisation des devoirs
faits en 6e qui permettent en moyenne
2h30 par semaine de soutien aux élèves
et je soulligne ici que ce sont les
élèves de REP et REP plus qui en
bénéficient le plus au lycée leur
rétablissement dans le Tron commun de la
première générale d'unh30 obligatoire de
mathématique par semaine il faut avoir
la lucidité là aussi de le reconnaître
supprimer les mathématiques du Tron
commun a été une erreur de la même façon
positionner les épreuves de spécialité
du baccalauréat général et technologique
en mars n'était pas une bonne idée on
l'a vu cette année avec une très forte
augmentation de l'absentéisme et
globalement de la démotivation des
élèves après les épreuves de spécialité
en mars puisqueune grande partie d'entre
eux savaient à ce moment-là qu'ils
avaient leur baccalauréat avec les notes
des épreuves de spécialité et le
contrôleue nous avons la lucidité de le
reconnaître et je le crois le
pragmatisme d'y répondre c'est pour
répondre à votre question sur cette
décision que j'ai eu à prendre dès ma
nomination vous le savez j'ai fait le
choix non seulement après avoir échangé
avec les organisations syndicales et les
représentants des parents d'élèves et
des personnels de rétablir ces épreuves
en juin mais j'en ai profité pour
réaffirmer que l'année scolaire doit
aller jusqu'au bout du mois de juin et
que la reconquête du mois de juin est
une priorité absolue nous avons donc
positionné les épreuves assez tard dans
le mois de juin de sorte que dans les
deux premières semaines de juin tous les
élèves du lycée auront cours que dans la
2è quinzaine de juin il y aura les
premières et les terminales en épreuve
et que les élèves de Seconde réaliseront
un stage en entreprise en administration
en association ce qui veut dire que tous
les élèves seront mobilisés jusqu'à la
fin du mois de juin de la même manière
j'ai décidé de positionner les épreuve
du brevet des collèges le plus loin que
ce n'a jamais été au mois de juillet ça
a très rarement été au mois de juillet
pour que les élèves du collège reste en
cours jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin on
ne peut pas ambitionner d'élever le
niveau en acceptant que l'année scolaire
s'arrête pour des élèves de la fin du
mois de mai dans la voie professionnelle
la réforme que nous engageons en cette
rentrée augmentera d'un milliard d'euros
les moyens des lycées professionnels
permettra de développer les périodes de
formation des élèves en milieu
professionnel ces stages seront
désormais gratifiés de 50 à 100 € par
semaine ça permettra de déployer des
cours en petits effectifs dans les
enseignements généraux mais aussi de
créer de nouvelles options pour les
lycéens professionnels avec des cours
d'entrepreneuriat des cours de codage ou
des langues vivantes pour poursuivre
cette bataille des savoirs j'ai annoncé
la semaine dernière la mise en place
d'une mission avec des recteurs des
chercheurs des inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale des professeurs et
d'autres personnels de terrain qui me
remettront leur conclusion d'ici la fin
de l'année je le redis il y a urgence
pour élever le niveau et lutter contre
tous les déterminismes nous aurons je
l'espère l'occasion d' changer sur cette
mission et ces recommandations
fondamentales pour l'avenir de notre
pays vouloir élever le niveau c'est
évidemment aussi lutter contre les cours
perdus pour les élèves l'an dernier il y
a 15 millions d'heures de cours qui
n'ont pas été honorés pour les élèves 15
millions d'heures d'absence non
remplacé on peut pas ambitionner
d'élever le niveau avec 15 millions
d'heures de cours perdu sur une année
j'ai fait de ce sujet une priorité sur
ces 15 millions d'heures perdu la moitié
sont lié à l'organisation de notre
système et donc il faut éviter les
absences évitables en repositionnant les
épreuves de spécialité du mois de mars
Au mois de juin nous récupérons des
heures qui étaient perdues à cause de
l'organisation des examens j'ai assumer
j'assume le choix de positionner
désormais la formation continue des
enseignants en dehors du temps de classe
je dis pas en dehors du temps scolaire
et uniquement sur les vacances mais en
tout cas en dehors du temps de classe
c'est près de 2 millions d'heures de
cours l'an dernier qui ont été perdu du
fait de temps de formation des
enseignants sur le temps de la classe
pour ce qui est des absences qu'on ne
peut pas éviter il y en aura évidemment
toujours dans une administration 1200000
agents il nous faut améliorer notre
capacité de remplacement c'est donc pour
répondre à votre deuxième question sur
le PACT enseignant puisque vous savez le
PACT vise à mieux rémunérer mieux
soutenir les les enseignants qui
s'engagent notamment dans le
remplacement de courte durée il y en a
déjà beaucoup qui s'engageaient dans le
remplacement de courte durée euh ces
années précédentes en heures
supplémentaires ils seront désormais
rémunéré 50 % de plus pour ces missions
qu'ils effectuaient déjà jusqu'à l'année
dernière un enseignant qui faisait du
remplacement de courte durée été
rémunéré je crois 41 € brut de l'heure
avec le PACT enseignant ça passe à 70 €
brut de l'heure augmentation très
importante qui a vocation à ce qu'il y
ait évidemment davantage de remplacement
pour ces cours qui sont sinon perdu pour
pour les élèves vous m'interrogiez sur
la le déploiement du PACT j'ai eu
l'occasion de communiquer sur des
premiers chiffres mais qui sont vraiment
très préliminaire parce qu'il date de la
fin du mois de septembre plutôt la
deuxème début de la deuxième moitié de
septembre que toutes les académies n'ont
pas pu nous les faire remonter et que
vous le savez le recours au Pact dépend
beaucoup des protocoles sur le
remplacement signés dans chaque
établissement et que tous les
établissement n'avait pas signé leur
protocole et pourtant un enseignant sur
quatre s'est engagé dans le pacte
c'est même un sur TR au collège et un
sur TR au lycée professionnel ce qui est
quand même assez loin des prévisions
parfois on va dire terrible qui était
faite notamment par certains
observateurs ou certaines organisations
syndicales moi je veux les remercier
évidemment de s'être engagé dans le
pacte enseignant j'aurai l'occasion
d'avoir un nouveau bilan chiffré sur le
pacte au retour des vacances de la
toussin et évidemment je répondrai aux
questions que vous aurez sur ce sujet ma
deuxième priorité c'est de bâtir une
école des droits et devoirs c'est
d'abord un devoir de reconnaissance que
nous avons et que j'ai comme ministre
vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui font vivre
l'école cela passe en grande parti par
la rémunération en la matière là aussi
nous tenons nos engagements en cette
rentrée les professeurs sont rémunérés
entre 125 et 250 € net de plus par mois
qu'à la rentrée précédente septembre
2022 septembre 2023 et ce sans
conditions il y a eu deux
revalorisations du point d'indice une
revalorisation socle en cette rentrée ça
fait entre 125 et 250 € nets de plus par
mois entre septembre 22 et septembre 23
pour les professeurs néotitulaires qui
démarrent dans l'enseignement ils sont
désormais rémunérés 2100 € nets par mois
c'est même 2466 € en Rep plus avec ces
revalorisations inédites nous
effaçons en grande partie une génération
de déclassement salarial pour nos
professeurs et nous revenons exprimé en
point de Smic à un niveau de
rémunération supérieur par rapport à
celui de l'an 2000 c'est la plus forte
augmentation de salaire dans l'éducation
nationale depuis des décennies j'entends
évidemment qu'il y a en grande partie du
rattrapage justement de ces dernières
décennies j'entends que pour un certain
nombre d'enseignants c'est encore
difficile mais enfin il me semble
important de reconnaître qu'il n'y a pas
eu d'équivalent ces 30 dernières années
d'augmentation salariale dans
l'éducation nationale que ce que nous
avons fait c'est depuis la réélection du
président de la République depuis la
réélection du président en 2022
entre mi-2022 et janvier 2024 puisque
vous savez qu'il y a une dernière mesure
en janvier 2024 4 avec l'injection de 5
point d'indice majorés pour tous les
fonctionnaires mais qui bénéficiera
aussi au enseignants si on met bout à
bout ces mesures entre avril 2022 et
janvier 2024 c'est plus 11 % au global
en moyenne de revalorisation ce devoir
de reconnaissance nous le devons
également aux aesh qui accompagne chaque
jour les élèves en situation de handicap
dans leur scolarité en cette rentrée
plus de la moitié des aesh sont
désormais en CDI ce qui marque notre
volonté forte de déprécariser ce métier
l'an dernier on était à en dessous de 30
% d'Es en CDI par ailleurs toute
bénéficie d'une revalorisation de 10 à
13 %. évidemment si on veut
structurellement et véritablement
améliorer la rémunération des aesh c'est
sur le temps de travail qu'il faut jouer
si vous êtes à 24 he maximum par semaine
pour améliorer votre rémunération il
faut évidemment augmenter le volume
horaire c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous travaillons évidemment avec les
collectivité locale sur le temps
périscolaire nous travaillons aussi dans
les suites de la Conférence nationale du
handicap sur sur des missions
supplémentaires qui pourrai être confié
aux aesh pour leur permettre d'avoir un
temps complet et donc une meilleure
rémunération mais nous attendons pas ce
travail pour faire une revalorisation
nous poursuivons également l'effort de
recrutement à l'heure où je vous parle
nos effectifs et nos écoles comptent
15000 AES de plus qu'à la rentrée 2022
l'école des droits et devoirs c'est
aussi le respect de l'autorité du maître
et de l'autorité des savoirs c'est le
respect des principes les plus
élémentaires de notre République comme
la laïcité ces derniers mois nous le
savons les atteintes à la laïcité c'é
développé à un rythme inquiétant que
cela concerne la contestation des
enseignements en histoire géographie en
SVT ou dans d'autres disciplines ou bien
sûr le port de tenue non conforme à la
loi de 2004 vous le savez j'ai assumé
une décision importante au moment de ma
nomination une décision importante mais
qui en réalité n'aurait pas dû être vécu
comme telle puisqu'il s'agit simplement
de décider d'appliquer la loi la loi de
2004 ce qu' a confirmé le Conseil d'État
dans son avis qui a été remis suite aux
référés qui ont été conduits par
certaines associations sur ma décision
le Conseil d'État a confirmé que je ne
faisais qu'appliquer la loi de 2004 vous
m'avez interrogé monsieur le Président
sur la manière dont cette mesure s'est
appliquée je suis je le dis très
satisfait de la manière dont cette
mesure a été
appliquée nous avons eu sur la première
semaine de la rentrée scolaire autour
d'un milliers de contestations de la
règle par des élèves ce qui est peu par
rapport au nombre de tenue non conforme
qui était porté l'année dernière ce qui
montre qu'une grande partie des élèves
concernés s'était conformé à la règle
pour le jour de la rentrée et surtout
dans la quasi totalité des cas nous
sommes parvenus par la pédagogie et le
dialogue à régler ces situations et moi
je veux vraiment rendre hommage aux
chefs d'établissement à leurs équipes
aux équipes laïité valeur de la
République des rectorats qui étaient au
côté des chefs d'établissement pour
engager ce dialogue et cette pédagogie
avec les élèves et les familles pour moi
ça montre que quand il y a de la
pédagogie du dialogue bref de l'humain
on arrive à gérer des situations tendues
et c'est pour moi un enseignement y
compris que je porte pour la question du
harcèlement scolaire ma troisème
priorité c'est enfin de construire une
école qui émancipe et qui rend heureux
s'émanciper c'est pour nos élèves la
chance d'acquérir une autonomie d'esprit
un esprit critique une ouverture
intellectuelle à tous les savoirs et au
monde cette émancipation passe d'abord
par l'enseignement des humanités et de
la culture générale c'est pourquoi nous
étendons à tous les col l'accès au
passculture alors que plus de la moitié
des élèves de 4e et de 3e ont pu
bénéficier l'an passé d'une activité à
ce titre visiter un musée avec un guide
conférencier assister à une
représentation au théâtre pratiquer un
instrument de musique autant de
découvertes et de pratiques qui font
l'éducation artistique et culturelle de
notre jeunesse et que nous développons
en cette rentrée encore grâce à
l'extension du passeculture collectif à
l'école nous allons également refonder
pour la rentrée prochaine l'enseignement
moral et civique j'y tiens tout
particulièrement l'école doit non
seulement élever le niveau mais former
des républicains pour cela mon
prédécesseur a saisi le Conseil
supérieur des programmes qui me rendra
ses propositions d'ici la fin de l'année
je veillai tout particulièrement à la
place de nos institutions dans cet
enseignement à l'enseignement de la
laïcité et je sais Monsieur le Président
que la mission que vous conduisez sera
très utile là aussi pour enrichir ce
travail là avec le sujet de la BAA
évidemment on n pas réglé tous les
sujets d'application de la la à l'école
loin de là je rappelle que dans les
récentes études encore un enseignant sur
deux déclare s'autocensuré notamment
pour des raisons de contestation de la
laïcité dois donc poursuivre et
j'attends beaucoup de la mission qui est
conduite par les sénatrices et les
sénateurs sur ce sujet je veux avancer
aussi sur l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information don nous percevons chaque
jour l'utilité face aux tentations de
l'instantané et de l'immédiateté qui ne
remplaceront jamais l'esprit critique et
le débat éclairé l'objectif est que dès
la rentrée prochaine nous puissions
doubler le le temps dédié à
l'enseignement moral et civique dès la
5e enfin je ne saurais parler des droits
et devoirs d'une école qui rend heureux
sans parler du droit absolu pour chaque
élève de la République d'être en paix à
l'école oui le devoir du politique est
de garantir à chaque élève une scolarité
sereine je veux bien sûr parler du fléo
que représente le harcèlement scolaire
qui a déjà fait souffrir trop de nos
enfants et de leurs famille parfois
jusqu'à
l'irréparable chaque élève a le droit à
la parole chaque élève a le droit à
l'écoute chaque élève a le droit d'être
protégé voilà pourquoi le gouvernement
et avec lui j'en suis sûr une très large
majorité des membres du Parlement font
de la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire et le cyberhcèlement une cause
absolument prioritaire pour notre école
j'en ai fait en tout cas ma grande cause
pour l'école et je n'accepterai pas
qu'on oppose cette priorité là aux
autres que j'ai évoqué précédemment on
peut pas imaginer élever le niveau si on
a des centaines de milliers ou des
millions d'élèves qui sont malheureux à
l'école quand vous êtes harcelé le
harcèlement envahit totalement votre
esprit il n'y a plus de place pour autre
chose il y a plus de place pour les
apprentissages agir pour le bonheur des
élèves à l'école c'est aussi agir pour
élever le niveau parce qu'on leur permet
d'étudier et d'apprendre en
paix je l'ai dit nous devons
profondément nous remettre en question
sur ce sujet-là y compris dans les
pratiques qui ont pu exister dès cet été
j'ai publié un décret pour que désormais
ce soient les élèves harceleurs et non
les élèves harcelés qui soient contraint
de changer d'établissement dès cette
rentrée nous nous avons étendu le
programme phare pour que 100 % de nos
écoles collèges et lycées prennent
pleinement leur part à une démarche de
prévention de détection et de résolution
de chaque situation individuelle nous
devons remettre de l'écoute et de
l'humain à tous les étages des rectorats
à nos établissements dans chacune de nos
écoles dans chacun de nos collèges et
chacun de nos lycées de l'humain on ne
luttera pas contre le harcèlement avec
des plans ou avec des circulaires nous
réussiront et j'ai vu au Danemark mais
aussi dans certaines écoles de notre
pays de très belles réussites pour faire
reculer le harcè
nous réussirons si nous changeons
profondément de culture face au
harcèlement et si nous nous en donnons
les moyens les décisions que nous avons
présenté avec la première ministre il y
a quelques jours vise à traduire ce
changement de culture ça passe
évidemment par la poursuite du
renforcement de la formation des
personnels par la sensibilisation des
élèves et des parents par le
renforcement des moyens humains dans les
académies et la mise en place d'équipes
d'intervention
dédié le 9 novembre prochain se tiendra
dans tous nos établissements la journée
non au harcèlement et pour la première
fois dans notre histoire un temps dédié
sera consacré dans chaque salle de
classe à la prévention et au recueil de
la parole par ailleurs internet et les
réseaux sociaux ne doivent plus demeurer
des zones de non droit où nos enfants
naviguent en insécurité des formes de
cours d'école sans règles ni
supervisation par aucun adulte à cet
égard je me réjouis des amendements
adoptés par vos collègues députés dans
le cadre du projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
ces amendements qui ont été adoptés il y
a quelques minutes à l'Assemblée
nationale permettront aux juges
d'interdire à l'élève harceleur l'accès
aux réseaux sociaux pour une durée
jusqu'à 6 mois sans préjuger de l'issue
de la navette parlementaire j'ai la
conviction que ces mesures sont de
nature à participer au renforcement de
la lutte contre le cyber harcèlement
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs les Français attendent
beaucoup de leur école et ils ont raison
la libération de la parole que nous
observons ces dernières semaines sur le
harcèlement démontre non seulement
l'urgence à agir mais aussi tous les
progrès que nous pouvons accomplir si
nous sommes unis pour notre école au
fond toutes les priorités de l'agenda
que je viens de vous présenter sont
liées on ne peut pas élever le niveau je
le disais si nos élèves sont malheureux
à l'école on peut pas élever le niveau
si nos professeurs sont malheureux
d'enseigner ne retrouve pas la fierté et
le prestige d'un métier si indispensable
en démocratie on ne peut pas élever le
niveau Sion retrouve pas le sens des
principes à commencer par l'autorité du
maître et l'autorité des savoirs qui
permettent le progrès dans nos sociétés
pour conduire toutes ces transformation
je suis convaincu que nous saurons
trouver des points d'accord dans
l'intérêt supérieur du pays et de sa
jeunesse uni pour son école notre pays
n'en sera que plus fort et plus juste je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
première série de questions de notre
rapporteur budgétaire Jacques groperin
qui veillera ne pas poser toutes les
questions bien entendu
oui j'ai bien compris monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci de
votre propos quel programme quel
programme et quel programme j'avais en
son temps lors de lors de d'une audition
avec votre prédécesseur dit à votre
prédécesseur soyez ministre pesz et
cetera je ne doute pas de vos
convictions de vos enthousiasmes de
votre énergie et je voudrais tout
d'abord saluer ce qui n'est pas courant
de la part de d'une opposition politique
mais d'une opposition en tout cas
républicaine les gestes que vous avez eu
vis-à-vis de cette interdiction que vous
avez proposé et combien de fois nous
l'avons demandé au à votre prédécesseur
l'interdiction donc de la baaya et je
crois qu'un moment donné vous avez dit
vous avez assumé je crois que le terme
est bien été assumé la France en tout
cas les Français les chefs
d'établissement l'attendaient et et vous
en remercie la deuxième chose je
voudrais aussi euh euh vous féliciter
sur votre prise de position vis-à-vis
des courriers vis-à-vis de Versailles ce
sont des gestes qui ne sont pas anodins
parce que les parents vous écoutent vous
entendent et vous représentez le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale vous
représentez aussi quelque part la France
et enfin euh peut-être aussi vous dire
et et dans cette période singulière tout
à l'heure sur les question d'actualité
avec où il y avait beaucoup de
d'émotions la visite ce matin d'une
école juive à sarcell avec le ministre
de l'intérieur c'est un moment important
qui est regardé et c'est grâce à des
moments comme ça que vous pourrez que
vous symbolisez la République mais vous
pourrez aussi à un moment donné apporter
beaucoup de choses à la République et à
are nation qui en ce moment souffre j'ai
entendu je je serai pas trop long parce
qu'il y aura d'autres moments le
président l'a fort bien dit tout à
l'heure sur le sur sur en tout cas le
financement de de de ce de votre projet
en tout cas de ce projet-l il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
mais simplement je voudrais vous alerter
faites attention au niveau de la
communication parce qu'à vouloir trop
communiquer à un moment donné on peut
perturber les uns et les autres on peut
perturber les chefs d'établissements on
peut perturber les enseignants on peut
perturber parfois les élèves et et je
comprends votre élan votre enthousiasme
et votre envie parce qu'on vous demande
tellement en même temps que c'est
tellement difficile et que vous avez
envie certainement de tellement bien
faire euh sur les les trois points
remettre l'aspect l'autorité savoir
fondamentaux on va pas refaire
l'histoire sur ce qui se passe en France
mais on aura quand même un
questionnement à voir un jour à ce qui
se passe véritablement en classe dans la
classe mais là il y a quelque chose qui
est de l'ordre du du chef du pas de chef
d'établissement mais de l'enseignant et
c'est pas toujours facile de mais
véritablement il faudra se poser la
question de ce qui se passe parce que on
a le premier budget on l'a dit tout à
l'heure 100 milliard mais je crois que
un moment donné on peut être aussi en
demande d'autres choses vous avez dit
garantir à chaque élève chaque jour un
prof face à lui ça c'est fondamental là
je le relirai par rapport à la formation
continue lorsque vous avez dit 15
millions d'heur qui n'avent qui ne sont
pas enseigné dont 10 % dans le casadre
de la formation continue vous proposez
que ça soit alors vous faites la nuance
dans le temps scolaire dehors de l'école
école et cetera je crois que on a bien
vu qu'avec la ministre Belkassem même en
posant à un moment donné une
rémunération mêmeosant d'autres choses
ça n'a pas marché comment vous allez
inciter les enseignants inciter j'ai pas
dit obligé à pouvoir fonctionner dans le
cadre en tout cas de faire cette
formation continue en sachant que les
enseignants en France parce que la
priorité c'est le français les
mathématiques les enseignants du
français ont deux fois moins de
formationsue que leurs collègues de
l'OCDE vous n avez parlé faire une une
école ou un lieu où chaque enfant puisse
être heureux et la lutre de harcelement
que vous ne concurrencez pas avec le
reste c'est fondamental mais euh je
voudrais faire référence à la médecine
scolaire médecine scolaire il y a une
concurrence très forte vis-à-vis euh euh
de d'autres organismes et on voit bien
nous dans le département du dou il y a
15 euh emploi ETP et il y en a que cinq
qui sont en tout cas occupés quand je
dis médecine scolaire c'est aussi
infirmier et il participe aussi à au
repérage vis-à-vis du harcèlement la
souffrance et cetera et cetera donc ce
sont des choses qui me qui me semblent
fondamentales euh vous nous avez parlé
également euh des semaines entreprises
pour les élèves de seconde et cetera
alors ça c'est une période aussi qui est
à cheval entre les périodes du SNU
faisons attention le SNU auss c'est une
priorité du président de la République
comment vous allez l'organiser pour
comment donné on puisse gérer cela parce
qu'il nous paraît important et ces
annonces ont fait qu'un moment donné il
y a une crise pas pas une crise mais ça
crée des attentes chez les
personneléducation national ça crée des
attentes chez les entreprises et ça
prisque à un moment donné de poser
problème et enfin euh sur le pacte
d'enseignement j'en ai parlé euh moi
j'aimerais euh vous parler de
l'excellent rapport et surtout
proposition de loi de notre excellent
collègue Max Brisson euh pour uneéco la
liberté l'égalité des chances et la
laïcité dans tout ce que vous présentez
aujourd'hui dans tout ce que vous
proposez il y a des pistes qui sont
intéressantes alors je vais pas prendre
l'article 4 sur l'article 3 sur euh sur
euh les dérogations modalités
d'affectation des enseignants mais pour
qu'un enseignant fonctionne bien et
puiss ê efficace pourut qu'il se S bien
mais l'article 4 qui est la création des
écoles supérieures du professeurat des
écoles parce qu'il y a un vrai problème
de la formation et je pense que redonner
à l'éducation nationale en tout cas la
formation qu'elle reprenne en main cette
formation du premier degré avec cette
création des écoles supérieures du
professeurat des écoles ça pourrait être
aussi un chemin que vous pourrez prendre
pour
pouvoir pas conclure mais en tout cas
engager dans ce vaste projet cette
vaste en tout cas pardon l'énergie que
vous avez et en tout cas souhaite une
grande réussite dans l'éducation
nationale parce que ça touche grand
nombre de familles grand nombre
d'enseignants grand nombre d'enfants
grand nombre d'élèves et grand nombre de
parents merci ministre je vais vous
laisser répondre aux questions du
rapporteur qui a déjà abordé un certain
nombre de de sujets dans on va
dire merci monsieur le Président et
merci au rapporteur je vais revenir sur
les différentes questions vous avez
commencé par la formation continue moi
je le redis j'assume ce choix de
positionner donner la formation continue
en dehors des heures de cours pour
limiter au maximum les heures de cours
qui sont perdues pour nos élèves pour
autant j'assume de dire aussi qu'on a
besoin de formation continue évidemment
qu'on a besoin que les enseignants
puissent accéder et recour à la
formation continue c'est pourquoi je
pense que cette décision peut-être une
opportunité pour améliorer le recours à
la formation continue parce que parfois
en écoutant certains débats où regardant
certains commentaires j'ai l'impression
que certains estiment que l'organisation
de la formation continue au aujourd'hui
serait parfaite ou idéale il y a moins
d'un enseignant sur de au collège qui a
recours et à peine plus d'un enseignant
sur 3 au lycée qui a recours souvent
parce que ils le disent il y a de très
bons formateurs il y a de très bonnes
formations mais l'organisation elle-même
de la formation ne répond pas totalement
à notre attente on veut des modules plus
courts c'est câbles en hybride sur site
dans notre établissement en collectif
avec nos collègues et c'est exactement
ça qu'on va être qu'on va mettre en
place et qu'on est en train de mettre en
place raison pour laquelle la décision
que j'ai prise s'applique de manière
progressive il s'agit pas de dire on
passe du jour au lendemain à plus aucune
formation continue sur le temps de la
classe j'ai dit 30 % en cette rentrée 50
% au 1er janvier prochain 100 % à la
rentrée prochaine ce qui laisse le temps
à nos écoles académiques de formation
continue réseau canopé et autres de
déployer leur offre de la réadapter pour
qu'on puisse avoir un meilleur recours à
la formation continue sur la formation
initiale c'était la dernière question
mais comme c'est sur la formation je je
couple les deux oui il faut une profonde
réforme de la formation initiale des
enseignants
c'est à la fois un levier essentiel pour
l'élévation du niveau de nos élèves mais
c'est aussi un levier essentiel pour le
bien-être de nos enseignants et c'est un
levier essentiel pour l'attractivité du
métier d'enseignant moi je crois pas du
tout à une crise des vocations je crois
pas du tout qu'il a une crise des
vocation il y a un étudiant sur 4 qui
déclare être intéressé par
l'enseignement même 12 % sur un gros
volume qui disent envisager très
sérieusement de devenir enseignant et
par ailleurs on a tous autour de nous
des exemples de personnes qui a 30 40 ou
50 ans après une première carrière
parfois dans le privé ou dans le public
se disent j'ai envie de donner du sens à
mon travail et j'envisage de devenir
enseignant je pense au contraire qu'on a
plus de vocation aujourd'hui qu'on en a
connu c'est pas une crise de vocation
c'est une crise d'attractivité qu'on n
pas les seuls à connaître j'étais à
Hambourg hier avec le président de la
République l'Allemagne anticipe
peut-être jusqu'à 25 une pénurie de
25000 enseignants dans les années qui
viennent ils ont un problème
démographique qu'on a pas qu'on a moins
mais ils sont font face à cette
difficulté au Canada il manque 5000
enseignants et aux États-Unis vous avez
des États qui réduisent la taille des
programmes dans certains états par
manque d'enseignant donc c'est une crise
d'attractivité qui est mondiale parce
que je pense que mondialement il y a
aussi une perte du respect de l'autorité
de l'enseignant de cette figure et en
fait une perte du respect de l'autorité
des savoirs dans la société la première
expression de l'autorité du savoir c'est
l'enseignant si on ne respecte plus les
savoirs on ne respecte plus
l'enseignant la relation entre un
enseignant et ses élèves ça n'est pas
une relation d'égal à égal il y a celui
qui sait et il y a celui i qui apprend
et la relation entre un enseignant et
les familles n'est pas non plus une
relation d'égal à égal et je pense que
c'est toujours important de le rappeler
et de le redire en tout cas nous
politique on a cette possibilité par ce
discours quand même de rappeler des
choses qui nous semblent à nous
évidentes mais qui malheureusement ne
sont plus totalement pour tout le monde
c'est ce que disent eux-mêmes les
enseignants ensuite sur l'attractivité
il y a la question de la formation
initiale aujourd'hui vous avez des
enseignants qui sont formés au niveau
master avec un concours à VAC + 5 et
pourtant vous avez un enseignant sur 5
seulement qui se dit suffisamment formé
à la gestion sa classe pourtant il y a
des difficultés on le sait parfois et
pourtant on a une année de m2 qui par le
positionnement du concours en bac + 5
est devenu beaucoup trop chargé ça
réduit le vivier les les étudiants en M2
il cumulent l'alternance les cours la
rédaction du mémoire il y en a beaucoup
qui démissionnent qui ne sont pas
titularisés donc on doit revoir la
formation des enseignants et notre
ambition je pense que ça rejoint la
philosophie de ce que vous avez présenté
dans dans votre texte c'est de créer les
écoles normales du 21e siècle avec une
possibilité on a lancé une concertation
avec les organisations syndicales par
ailleurs je discute aussi avec ma
collègue syvier rotillot évidemment
immédiatement concerné puisqu'elle est
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
avec une possibilité d'avoir un concours
positionné avant le bac + 5 compris des
bac + 3 et ensuite une entrée
progressive dans le métier qui permet de
garder le niveau master une partie des
recrutements qui pourra être fait par
prérecrutement dès le niveau bac et
ensuite avec avec une une formation
extrêmement dense notamment sur les
fondamentaux et sur un certain nombre de
valeurs essentielles bref beaucoup de
possibilités et on en discute en ce
moment avec les organisations syndicales
euh troisème sujet que vous avez abordé
et j'accélère la médecine scolaire oui
on a besoin de médecine scolaire et
notamment sur la question du harcèlement
parce qu'on sait il y a des élèves qui
ont du mal à parler à leurs enseignants
qui ont du mal à parler aux chefs
d'établissement qui ont du mal à parler
à leur famille et parfois les personnels
sanitair ou sociaux c'est des voix ou
des oreilles à qui les élèves se sentent
de parler et oui on a une vraie
difficulté et là aussi c'est une
difficulté d'attractivité puisque vous
l'avez dit les postes sont là mais ils
ne sont pas pourvus sur les médecins on
sait on a un problème global de nombre
de médecins dans notre pays il ne sera
vraiment résolu que dans quelques années
quand les mesures qu'on a assumé au
début du précédent quinena sur le
numerus closus commenceront à produire
leurs effets avec les étudiants
concernés qui arriveront sur le terrain
et d'ici là je pense qu'on doit inventer
aussi de nouvelles manières de
travailler faire coopérer davantage nos
établissements scolaires avec la
médecine de ville avec les
établissements de santé et y compris
pour les infirmières scolaires moi je
pense que ça peut aussi être un levier
d'attractivité pour une infirmière
scolaire que de se dire je peux occuper
un emploi public dans un établissement
et en même temps avoir une activité en
libérale à côté si je le souhaite parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas possible donc
on est en train de travailler à ces
solutions il y a beaucoup d'efforts qui
ont été fait sur la rémunération des
personnels de santé à l'école ces
dernières années avec un réhaussement
des gris indiciaires avec la prime euh
pour les REP REP plus qui leurit
maintenant versé depuis janvier dernier
il y a peut-être encore des efforts à
faire on va regarder mais en tout cas il
me semble que c'est pas uniquement la
question financière qui nous permettra
de répondre euh à cet enjeu enfin et
dernier point sur la question du stage
pour les élèves de Seconde d'abord il
est très important et moi j'y tiens
beaucoup les pays qui réussissent mieux
que nous sur l'orientation si on prend
l'exemple de l'Allemagne de la Suède des
Pays-Bas c'est des pays où il y a 3 qu
semaines de stage nous là on dit juste
on rajoute 2 semaines en secondes
en plus de la semaine en
3e alors oui c'est un défi parce qu'ils
réaliseront tous leur stage au même
moment c'est pour ça qu'on va devoir se
mobiliser j'ai vu la présidente Carole
Delga des régions de France François
bonau Rena musolier les présidents de
régions sont très engagés sur ce
sujet-là ils me l'ont dit il y aura une
vraie mobilisation de leur part du tissu
économique les présidents de région
eux-mêmes demandaient la mise en place
d'un stage en seconde donc ils ont été
exaucés et évidemment ils se
mobiliseront j'ai eu les présidents de
fédération du patronat aussi qui se
mobiliseront c'est dans leur intérêt que
de faire découvrir aussi leurs métiers
leurs entreprises à nos élèves on
mobilisera les administration pour leur
proposer des stages s'agissant de votre
question sur le l'articulation avec le
SNU évidemment des élèves qui
réaliseraient le SNU à ce moment-là
seront dispensés de réaliser un stage
mais on les leur proposera de réaliser
un stage à un autre moment et on les
accompagnera pour ça donc il y aura pas
de concurrence entre les
dispositifs alors nous allons prendre
maintenant la première série de
questions vous êtes très nombreux à
vouir poser une question ce qui est très
bien par contre je vais vous demander
d'être très incisif et d'aller
directement à la question pour que
chacun puisse s'exprimer on va prendre
un représentant par groupe je vous donne
dans l'ordre de prise de parole comme ça
vous pouvez vous préparer Marie- piierre
Monier Lord Arcos George laelc Max
Brisson Sonia de la
provuté Monique DEC Bernard fialer
Samana casbon et em
durx merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
alors vous venez monsieur de Monsieur le
Ministre de nous refaire les annonces
qui ont marqué la rentrée scolaire un
empilement d'annonce j'ai envie de dire
que l'on a du mal à interpréter
autrement qu'une tentative peut-être de
diversion dans un contexte où la
première promesse qui devrait être celle
de l'école promesse d'ailleurs martelée
depuis plusieurs mois par l'exécutif
c'est de garantir la présence d'un
enseignant devant chaque élève et la
promesse n'a pas été tenue face à la
fragilisation sans précédent de notre
école laïque publique et républicaine il
est plus que jamais nécessaire de
restaurer la confiance vous avez parler
d'humain mais il faut restaurer la
confiance et le dialogue avec tous les
membres de la communauté
éducative alors que au contraire vous
faites le choix d'une démarche très
verticale sous-couvert vous en avez
reparlé de groupes de travail à qui sont
allouer si j'ai bien compris 8 semaines
seulement 8 semaines pour relever le
défi de l'amélioration du niveau des
élèves vous parlez de concertation
auprès de l'ensemble des enseignants
mais les lignes directrices sont connues
d'avance dans notre rapport bilan des
mesures éducatives du quinquena publié
en février 2022 et mené avec mes
collègues Max Brisson et Nic billon nous
pointions les dérives d'une politique
publique menée dans la précipitation et
à la mise en œuvre mal accompagnée j'ai
bien peur que ce nouveau quin ne tire
pas la leçon des erreurs commises
précédemment mes questions mont porter
d'abord à nouveau sur la pénurie
d'enseignant et je parle d'une enquête
qui a été faite par le
nspd UNSA qui pointait le manque de dans
de plus d'un enseignant dans 58 % des
collèges et des lycées à la rentrée et
je vous le dis à ce jour j'ai encore des
mails de différents établissements où
ils me disent qu'il manque d'enseignant
quelles sont les solutions prévues pour
garantir une présence d'un enseignant
qualifié devant les élèves et j'insiste
sur qualifier parce que c'est un
préalable indispensable pour garantir
l'éducation de nos enfants dans de
bonnes conditions dans un collège de
Gironde c'est le proviseur qui a publié
des petites annonces et envoyé une
lettre aux parents d'élèves pour qu'on
lui communique des CV c'est ma collègue
Laurence Sibé qui m'en a fait
part comment faire face au déficit de
remplacement tout au long de l'année à
venir dans un contexte où comme vous
l'expliquiez vous-même dans une récente
interview au Monde les remplaçants sont
déjà positionnés sur des postes vacants
dès la
rentrée signature de contrat alors là de
graves dysfonctionnement en matière de
signature de contrat et de rémunération
des personnels non enseignants AED aesh
assistants ou assistante social sociaux
des assistants administratifs qui n'ont
à 7 he toujours pas de contrat et pas de
rémunération depuis début septembre en
Drome la situation est tellement
dramatique que la commission
départementale d'Action Sociale a duû
hier attribuer des aides d'urgence à
plusieurs personnels à cause de
cela alors il y aurait plusieurs facteur
le premier c'est peut-être le manque de
personnel administratif au rectorat
c'est aussi un nouveau logiciel qui
peut-être dysfonctionnerit ou serait pas
adapté mais il y a quand même peut-être
aussi
l'impréparation de la mise en place de
la cdisation des aesh et des AED est-ce
que vous pouvez nous faire un état des
lieux à ce sujet et nous indiquer
comment vous prévoyez de régulariser au
plus vite la situation de tous ces
personnels qui ne peuvent pas rester
sans contrat ni salaire presque un mois
et demi après la
rentrée il y a aussi un problème avec
les assistants sociaux les contrats de
contractuel à CDD non signés conduisant
à des professionnels à nouveau qui sont
en train de travailler sans salaire hors
cadre légal pour le ha il y a aussi un
non déploiement des moyens nécessaires
pour couvrir l'ensemble des besoins et
pourtant tout à l'heure vous avez
insisté sur tout le travail à faire
contre le harcèlement scolaire et ce
sont des personnels qui sont justement
là pour la lutte contre lecellement
scolaire pouvez-vous m'indiquer comment
vous allez régulariser leur situation et
vous assurer que les postes doivent être
créés alors le pacte enseignant dernière
question dernière question mais
justement je reviens la revalorisation
des
salaires vous avez en effet beaucoup
communiqué en disant que chaque
enseignant percevrait chaque mois entre
125 et 250 € net en plus mais c'est pas
vrai puisque la revalorisation du point
d'indice de la fonction publique et
d'autres avantages ainsi que la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat de
rentrée sont intégré dans ce calcul la
hausse de 10
% pour tous les enseignants n'a pas été
honoré
et donc ce Pact les remontées qu'on a
pareil du syndicat
snmpd et
UNSA disent que il n'aurait pas été
signé dans 30 % des collèges et des
lycées à la rentrée alors nous nous
avons une position très claire nous
sommes contre la logique du pacte
enseignant celle de fait de pouvoir
gagner plus si on doit travailler plus
donc comment et qu'il y a de grandes
disparités aussi au niveau des
territoires donc comment allez-vous
désormais assurer ACC de ces dispositifs
d'accompagnement de l'ensemble des
élèves sur le territoire et je vous je
vous alerte sur deux points sur ce Pact
il y a des enseignants qui sont amenés à
remplacer des collègues absents pendant
leurs heures de service je connais le
CAN un documentaliste donc il est payé
pour des heures de travail effectué
simultanément et des enseignants ou des
enseignantes effectuent des
remplacements dans des matières qui ne
sont pas les leurs trouvez-vous ces
situations normales et sont-elles
répandues sur le territoire merci vous
êtes une vingtaine à vouloir s'exprimer
donc si chacun prend 5 minutes on en a
pour plus d'une heure donc s'il vous
plaît soyez vraiment concis Lord Arcos
qui va montrer l'exemple de la concision
ou voilà j'ai le poids oui monsieur le
Président mais je vais je suis content
d'avoir le ministre en face de moi parce
que je vais quand même aussi donner un
un témoignage un peu poignant une
question d'abord très simple très clair
l'année dernière à la même époque j'ai
interrogé votre prédécesseur concernant
les maths dans le Tron commun au
baccalauréat parce que la réforme avait
fait en sorte qu'il n'y avait plus de
math dans le Tron
commun ça a été rétabli à moitié puisque
ça n'est qu'en première et en terminale
ça n'est toujours pas le cas et que du
coup ceux qui veulent poursuivre les
mathématiques en terminal se retrouvent
en fait dans des classes avec des matsp
et des gens qui sont beaucoup plus
évolués en terme de mathématiqu et
vraiment je vous assure pour être sur je
dis devant aussi mon collègue David Ross
sur le plateau de sa clé ça fait donc
deux promotions que nous n'avons plus
assez de candidats pour les écoles
d'ingénieurs aujourd'hui on va manquer
d'é de d'ingénieur moi je me battais
pour les femmes dans dans les milieux
scientifiques mais là c'est garçons et
filles et donc là c'est vraiment un
sujet quelque chose de beaucoup plus
grave parce que j'étais très touché par
ce que vous avez dit en disant faut que
chaque enfant soit heureux dans dans sa
classe deux exemples un premier je sais
que vous pouvez pas changer la face du
monde en en un claquement de doigt qu'il
manque beaucoup de
CSH mais il manque aussi beaucoup de
place en imee et je vous le dis parce
que il faut aussi que vous en parliez à
votre collègue moi j'ai à La Ville du
Bois un seul exemple de an enfant les
parents savent très bien qu'il devrait
aller en IME et ils ont pas de place il
y a pas deesh et bien ils sont à l'école
de La Ville du Bois on les appellent les
enfants du couloir depuis le début de
l'année ils serent dans les couloirs
parce qu'ils n tiennent pas en place et
qu'aujourd'hui et ben ils sont dans les
couloirs à
déambuler devant leurs petits camarades
et je pense que ça c'est absolument
intenable deuxième témoignage qui me
tient particulièrement à cœur Célian et
sont dans un lycée à d'dan euh en
première STMG et depuis 15 jours ils
subissent un harcèlement scolaire
absolument épouvantable ils se réfugi au
dans le CDI pour à l'heure de la
récréation ou du déjeuner pour ne pas
subir de
d'insulte le le proviseur a refusé de
recevoir et les parents jeauris demandé
de d'appeler le
3618 on a eu une empathie formidable
c'est-à-dire un mail avec les médiateurs
de du directorat versaill voilà leur
numéro de téléphone et si ça va pas
appeler le ministre ben joigz le
ministre j'en ai parlé à Charlotte cobel
parce que c'est aussi son problème mais
j'en ai parlé à la daen la dazen a dû
sûrement remonter les bretelles du
proviseur qui n'a rien trouvé de mieux
que d'exposer ses deux gamins devant la
classe parce qu'en fait c'est pas un
harcèlement de deux deux élèves contre
deux élèves c'est un harcèlement de deux
élèves contre l'ensemble de la classe
parce qu'ils veulent travailler et la
seule chose qu'on leur a dit c'est vous
avez une bonne éducation vous venez
d'ailleurs du privé vous comprenez les
pauvres ils n'ont pas de code donc il y
a du racisme anti blanc et du racisme
entre guillemets intellectuel en fait on
les traite d'uno et ils veulent pouvoir
travailler donc ces enfants sont
aujourd'hui chez eux parce qu'ils ont
été arrêtés ils vont suiv une
psychothérapie et demande qu'une seule
chose c'est changer d'établissement pour
cette fois-ci je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est mieux que ça soit le harcellerur
qui quitte la classe mais dans ce cas-là
je vous en conjure essayer de m'aider
pour queil puisse changer
d'établissement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi de me présenter
je suis sénateur des code d'Armor et
pardonnez-moi aussi de le dire ici je
suis le fils d'un ouvrier agricole et
d'une ménagère sans
profession habitant à 4 km
du du bourg d'une commune de 570
habitants je dois donc à l'école de la
République d'avoir fait de moi ce que
modeste je
suis mes premiers mots sont donc des
mots de reconnaissance pour la grande
institution dont présidez vous présidez
la destinée et c'est donc avec respect
et solennité que je m'adresse à vous
monsieur le ministre alors s'il est vrai
que l'école ne peut pas tout il n'est
pas moins vrai que l'école peut beaucoup
et notre société en attend beaucoup je
voudrais
commencer par vous donner acte d'un
certain nombre d'annonces que vous vous
avez faite dans votre propos liminaire
et d'un certain nombre
d'infléchissements que vous avez
apportés je pense par exemple au
mathématique qu'on réhabilite un peu
d'ACT mais il y a deux points
particuliers qui ont retenu mon
attention le premier point c'est celui
de la dite carte
scolaire carte scolaire à laquelle nous
avons été confrontés dans bon nombre de
nos territoires et en particulier dans
nos territoires
ruraux parce que vous le savez
nos collectivités se s'engagent
beaucoup notamment en créant ces RPI ces
regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux d'ailleurs qui constittu
peut-être un bout de réponse à la crise
de la démographie dont vous parliez dans
vos propos liminires donc autrement dit
on vise un objectif de qualité on se
rassemble on mobilise bien au-delà
d'ailleurs de la communauté éducative
les familles les collectivités et cetera
et s'agissant de ces fameuses cartes
scolaires je me demande si préalablement
à toute restructuration s'il ne serait
pas mieux d'engager en
amont une démarche visant la recherche
de la qualité éducative du à tout le
monde c'est-à-dire que plutôt que d'être
dans une logique d'application des
caucients mathématique la règle de
3 consistante à vouloir mettre en
adéquation je dirais les effectifs et
les effectifs scolaires et le nombre
d'enseignants si en amont nous engagions
une démarche visant une offre éducative
de qualité ce serait une bonne manière à
mes yeux une meilleure manière d'aborder
la qualité éducative dans leond dans le
monde rural
notamment en second lieu mais ça a été
abordé à l'instant comme vous je
considère que nous sommes confrontés à
une crise de l'attractivité des métiers
de l'enseignement par conséquent nous
sommes preneurs de toutes les précisions
que vous pourriez apporter et il me SEM
voilà pour cette audition de Gabriel
Atal le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui s'est exprimé devant les
sénateurs de la commission de la culture
et de l'éducation avec de très nombreux
sujets abordés en cette rentrée pour
cette audition sous forme de prise de
contact revalorisation du salaire des
enseignants mais aussi harcèlement
scolaire ou encore réforme du bac en
revanche vous l'avez vu pas de sujet
financier au programme de cette audition
ils seront abordé lors d'une prochaine
audition à l'occasion de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances 2024 vous
pouvez voir et revoir toutes les séances
toutes les auditions sur notre
plateforme numérique
publicsenat.fr tout de suite vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas HUG et sens
public pour une nouvelle édition
spéciale consacrée à la situation en
Israël très bonne soirée sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat